how is money created
where does it come from
who benefits
and what purpose does it serve what is a
money system what is the money behind
the money system
for centuries the mechanics of the
monetary system have remained hidden
from the prying eyes of the populace
yet its impact both on a national and
international level
is perhaps unsurpassed
for it is the monetary system that
provides the foundations for
international dominance
and national control
today
as these very foundations are being
shaken by crises
the need for open and honest dialogue on
the future of the monetary system
has never been greater
this economic crisis is like a cancer if
you just wait and wait thinking this is
going to go away
just like a cancer is going to grow and
it's going to be too late what i would
say to everybody is
get prepared
this is not a time right now to
wishful thinking the government is going
to sort things out the governments don't
rule the world goldman sachs rules the
world
we're on the verge of a perfect storm
in opposition like corrupt and
entrenched interests
that lurk in the corridors of power
for whom there are no reasons to
relinquish privileges they feel are
justly deserved
has he got has he got a reform plan for
the nhs no has he got a police report
plan
has he got a plan to cut the deficit
[Applause]
do you trust the government
order try to calm down and behave like
an adult and if you can't if it's beyond
you leave the chamber get out we'll
manage without you this is about
there's no coincidence that boom and bar
started to become a real cyclical issue
around about the 1700s
when william patterson founded the bank
of england
[Applause]
is in total behavior as far as the
public no it's not funny
only in your mind is it funny it's not
funny at all it's disgraceful
the system is inherently unstable as a
result of the international power it
provides to the dominant parties
for at the heart of it lies the idea of
how can i get something for nothing
statistical analysis have found that
every time an empire begins to near its
own demise you'll find that its currency
will be debased there is no guide to how
this whole system operates
to give you an example a researcher at
the bbc working on the older pests and
documentary went to the bank of england
and said can you give me a you know a
guide to how money is created
and they just said no
this documentary will investigate and
explain this ever-changing system
and the impact it has
both on a national and international
level
[Music]
in 2010 the total uk money supply stood
at 2.15 trillion pounds
2.6 percent of this total was physical
cash 53.5 billion
the rest
2.1 trillion or 97.4 percent of the
total money supply was commercial bank
money
the three percent of money um is created
uh through the central bank and that
money essentially
if you created a 10 pound note
you could sell that to a bank to put
into their atm and the bank would have
to repay that 10 pound or buy it for 10
pounds there'd be no interest made
charged on that money but that money is
then essentially transferred to the
treasury and it's a it's a it's a form
of fundraising
for the government it's called sinaroj
[Music]
when the bank of england creates a
10-pound note it
costed about three or four pence to
actually print that note and it sells it
to the high street banks at face value
so 10 pounds
and
the profit the difference between
printing the note and actually selling
it for 10 pounds goes directly to the
treasury
so in effect all the profit that we get
on creating
physical money uh banknotes
goes to the treasury and it reduces how
much taxes we have to pay
over the last 10 years that's raised
about 18 billion pounds
in 1948
notes and coins constituted 17 of the
total money supply
this was one contributing factor in the
government's ability to finance post-war
reconstruction
this included the establishment of the
nhs
in only 60 years notes and coins have
shrunk to less than three percent
prior to 1844 banknotes were created by
private banks and the government did not
profit from their creation
pre
pre-industrialization there was multiple
forms of money coexisting and so the
kind of rise of kind of
of government sponsored fear money is a
relatively recent
um
phenomenon in the 1840s there was no law
to stop banks from creating their own
banknotes so they used to issue
paper notes
as as kind of a
representative of what you had in the
bank account instead of you taking your
heavy metal coins out of the bank and
then going and paying somebody with them
you could get your paper which said how
much money you had in the bank you could
give that to somebody and they could use
that to go and get the heavy metal coins
from the bank
now over time these paper notes became
as good as money people would use the
paper notes instead of going and getting
the real money from the bank
and
obviously as soon as the banks realized
that
what they were creating had become
you know the dominant type of money in
the economy they realized that by by
creating more of it they could generate
profits you know they can just print up
some new notes
lend it and get the interest on top of
that and they did that you know up until
the 1840s in the 1840s they pushed it
just a little bit too far
and that caused inflation it
destabilized the economy
so in 1844
the
conservative government of rob appeal
actually passed a law
that took the power to create money away
from the commercial banks and brought it
back to the state so since then the bank
of england has been the only
organization authorized to
to create paper notes
since then everything's gone digital and
what we now use as money is the digital
numbers that commercial banks can create
out of nothing
[Music]
the problem was
that they did not include in that in
that legislation
the deposits the demand deposits
held in banks by individuals
or
electronic forms of money which
essentially what those demand deposits
are today most of the money
in circulation is is electronic money
um and it's bank it's bank um demand
deposits um that just that sit in our in
our account so in a way the legislation
has got
needs to catch up with developments in
in electronic money
and the way that banks actually operate
money held in bank accounts are called
demand deposits
this is an accounting term the banks use
when they create credit
banks follow the same process when they
create loans
all money held in bank accounts
is an accounting entry
[Music]
the reality is now that most money is
not paper and it's not metal coins it's
digital it's just numbers in a computer
system you know it's your visa debit
card it's your electronic you know atm
card
um
it's this is plastic you know it's
numbers in the computer system
you move money from one computer system
to another it's all a big database
and this digital money is what we're now
using to make payments with it's what we
actually use to run the economy i think
a lot of people in the uk
probably think that the government or
the central bank
is in control of most most money in
circulation and issues new money
into circulation but that's
not the case it's private banks that
creates the vast majority of new money
in circulation and also decide
how it's allocated
the official terminology for this
accounting entry
is commercial bank money
when banks issue loans to the public
they create new commercial bank money
when a customer repays a loan
commercial bank money is destroyed
the banks keep the interest as profit
there's a lot of misconceptions about
the way banks work there was a poll done
by the coptin center where they
asked people
you know how how they thought banks
actually operated around 30 percent of
the public think that when you put your
money into the bank it just stays there
and it's safe and you can understand why
because you know every every child has a
piggy bank where you keep putting money
in and then when it's a rainy day you
smash it and you take that money out and
you spend it so a lot of people keep
this this idea of banking you know it's
somewhere safe to keep your money so
that it's there for whenever you need it
another the other 60 of people
assume that when you put your money in
that money is then being moved across to
somebody who wants to borrow it so you
have a pensioner who keeps saving money
or her entire life
and then her life savings have been lent
to some you know young people who want
to buy a house but actually banks don't
work like that
at the moment in the uk
money creation
and control is is largely in the hands
of private banks
uh about 97 to 98 percent of money
um that's that's created is is created
as bank
bank debt money you could call it
when banks issue money into circulation
as as loans essentially
this is very poorly understood
fact
it's not a conspiracy theory it's not a
um
it's not a crackpot theory it's
the way the bank of england describes
the process when banks make loans they
create new money
a few economists will realize the way
the money system works but if you don't
if you don't realize the way that money
works and you think that you know
everybody saving is going to work well
for the economy what really happens once
you understand the way the money system
works is that if everybody starts saving
the amount of money in the economy
shrinks and we have a recession so most
economists don't have this this full
picture they don't understand all
elements of the system they rely on
assumptions
on you know received knowledge without
actually going into the details and
you know money is money is the center of
the economy if you don't understand
where it comes from who it creates who
creates it and when it gets created then
how can you understand the entire
economy
when the vast majority of money that we
use now is not cash but it's electronic
money then whoever's creating the
electronic money is getting the proceeds
of creating that money and obviously
creating electronic money is much more
profitable than creating cash because
you don't have any production costs at
all
so
while we've got 18 billion over the
course of a decade
in profit from creating cash
the banks have actually created 1.2
trillion pounds
between 1998 and 2007 the uk money
supply tripled
1.2 trillion pounds was created by banks
whilst 18 billion pounds was created by
the treasury
a lot of people think when i say this or
when you say this or when positive money
say this that we're all just a bunch of
nutters but on the 9th of march in 2009
the governor of the federal reserve
ben bernanke gave the first ever
broadcast interview the governor of the
central bank the united states of
america had ever given
and the day before that he bailed out
aig and
which is a insurance company not even a
bank actually to the tune of about 160
billion dollars so the journalist system
now mr bernanke
where did you get 160 billion dollars to
bail out aig does that tax money that
the fed is spending it's not tax money
the banks have um accounts with the fed
much the same way that you have an
account in a commercial bank so to lend
to a bank we simply use the computer to
mark up the size of the account that
they have with the fed
so it's much more akin
although not exactly the same but it's
much more akin to printing money than it
is to borrowing
[Music]
banks create new money
whenever they extend credit
buy existing assets or make payments on
their own account which mostly involves
expanding their assets
when a bank buys securities such as a
corporate or government bond
it adds the bond to its assets
and increases the company's bank
deposits by the corresponding amount
[Music]
new commercial bank money enters
circulation when people spend the credit
that has been granted to them by banks
i found that
talking on the doorstep from august last
year round to august 2009 round to
the general election eight nine eight
nine months i suppose knocking on doors
is that when you try to explain how the
money system works
there's uh an almost inbuilt refusal
of people to accept that such a bizarre
situation could actually exist
no it can't possibly you know
you can't banks can't banks
don't create money out of thin air
that's ridiculous they can't do that
they lend out their depositors money
most people have an idea of how money is
they're used to their own way of
handling money
and they try and implement their own
idea of how how their small household
economy works
into the national economy and of course
it just doesn't work out it just doesn't
work out at all
by 2008 the outstanding loan portfolio
of bank created credit
also known as commercial bank money
stood at over two trillion pounds
as recently as 1982 the ratio of notes
and coins to bank deposits was 1 to 12.
by 2010 the ratio had risen to 1 to 37.
that is for every pound of treasury
created money
there was 37 pounds of bank created
money
in the 10 years prior to the 2007 crisis
the uk commercial bank money supply
expanded by between seven to ten percent
every year
a growth rate of seven percent is the
equivalent of doubling the money supply
every ten years
the amount of money they're creating out
of nothing is just incredible 1.2
trillion in the last 10 years
and there's
that money is being distributed
according to the priorities of the
banking sector you know not the
priorities of society
bank sector
itself grew from 1980 2.5 trillion
dollars
to 40 trillion dollars by assets
in 1980 global bank assets were worth 20
times the then global economy
by 2006 they were worth 75 times
according to the un
as the following chart shows
total bank assets of uk banks as a
percentage of gdp remain relatively
stable at 50 to 60 percent
up to the end of the 1960s
after that they shot up dramatically and
the real money in in the world
to be made today is not by producing
anything at all it's simply by forms of
speculating basically making money from
money that's the most profitable and and
by far and away
um the the biggest form of of of
activity of economic activity that
exists in the world today
today
banks are no longer restricted by how
much they can lend
and as such
how much new credit they can create out
of nothing
they are restricted solely by their own
willingness to lend
the issue with allowing banks to create
money there's two main issues firstly
the fact that they create this money
when they make loans
so
it guarantees that you know we have to
borrow all our money for the economy
from the banks
as such
to have a healthy growing economy the
government needs to put in place
strategies
to allow for ever increasing debt
the only way the government can create
additional purchasing power is by
getting itself and us into more depth
the second big issue with allowing banks
to create money
is that they have the incentive to
always create more you know they create
more money if they issue a loan they get
the bonuses and the commissions and the
incentives to create you know to lend as
much as possible you have to develop a
sales culture what did they do
they recruited an amazing guy lovely guy
andy hornby who came from asda
to turn the bank into a
supermarket retailing operation if you
trust
bankers to control the money supply the
money supply will just grow and grow and
grow
as will the level of debt until the
point where it crashes you know when
some people can't repay the debt and
then they'll stop lending
you hear politicians and journalists
saying you know we've we've been living
beyond our means we've become dependent
on debt we need to reign in our spending
and live within our means
um
it's not possible in the current system
you know
the reason why everybody's in debt now
is not because they've been recklessly
boring
we haven't borrowed all this money from
you know an army of pensioners who've
been saving up their whole lives
money in the current system is debt you
know it's created when banks make loans
so the only way in the current system
that we can have any money in the
economy you know the only way we can
have money for business trade is if we
borrowed it all from the banks
and it's the very opposite
of what the tory parties are doing today
which is that you have to create savings
before you can help the national health
service
and it's because economists have
completely confused those things both in
monetary policy terms
but also in economic thinking and
because most people
still harbor the the old-fashioned view
that you need savings before you can
invest
that we have the mess that we're in
today
now one of the reasons why we
find it difficult to understand
the banking system and credit creation
is that
we leave school without any money
and we go and get a job working as an
apprentice to a plumber we work really
hard all month at the end of the month
somebody puts money in our bank and so
for us the logic is you work and then
you get money you get savings in reality
you would never have got that job if
credit hadn't been created in the first
instance
it's a really important
um conceptual misunderstanding
and it isn't something that the public
just are guilty of economists don't
understand this stuff money doesn't come
out of economic activity
a lot of people have come across as kind
of assume that if you've got people if
you've got businesses and you've got
people doing things that somehow money
somehow
emerges out of the process of people
doing things doing economic making
things and growing things and selling
things and producing things that's how
money just emerges
it's not it's like oil in the car you
have to put it in
when i see david cameron talking about
how we need an economy not based on debt
but we need an economy based on savings
he just doesn't know what he's saying
it's ridiculous it's absolutely absurd
and it shows his complete lack of
understanding of how our money system
actually works what he's essentially
saying
is that we need an economy with no money
if everyone was saving we'd have mass
disappearing of money which is
essentially what a bank write-off is
essentially is people defaulting on
their debt which which essentially is
just money disappearing but if people
weren't taking on the debt then it's
just it's just such a joke it's such a a
amateur understanding of how our economy
works and how the monetary system works
and how money is actually created so
i really do get a laugh out of watching
what people are actually saying and
they're all just regurgitating what
they've learned off each other and you
just hear the same things and it just
makes me it it really gets on my nerves
when i hear people talking about
yeah we need more regulations we need to
regulate the way banks are actually and
the bonus it's all just one big smoke
screen and working on all the symptoms
of a greater disease which is really you
need to look at the the money system the
way money is created and if we don't
want any debt then we're essentially
saying we don't want any money and we
want a moneyless economy with the
exception of the three percent that's
created debt-free
you know it's a paradox under the
current system if you
if we as the public go into further debt
then that's going to put more money into
the economy and we're going to have a
boom when you have a boom it's easier to
borrow so people get into even more debt
and eventually you know this this cycle
continues it gets easier and easier to
get into debt until some people get over
in debt and then you know they default
they can't repay their mortgage that's
what happened then you know it happened
first in subprime america
and then you know that just
brings to a wave of defaults which will
ripple across the entire economy
the banks go insolvent then we're into a
financial crisis
um
and then the banks stopped landing and
you know they were excessively landing
in the boom
and then they stopped landing and then
that court makes the recession even
worse people lose their jobs and then
they become even more dependent on debt
just to survive basically you know we
have a
system where we have to borrow in order
to have an economy we have to be in debt
to the banks
and that that guarantees you know
massive profit for the banks
this is the boom bust cycle
and i have said before mr deputy speaker
no return to boom and bus
[Music]
net bank lending must forever increase
we're paying interest on every single
pound even if even if you think the
money belongs to you
somebody somewhere is paying interest on
that money the banking system has such a
huge impact on the world
but only because it supplies our
nation's money supply
we have to protect them we have to
subsidize them we have to allow them to
continue because the the disaster of of
a bank collapse
affects us all in a huge way and anyone
that says that we shouldn't have bailed
out the banks doesn't quite understand
the the nature of our monetary system
that's like eliminating a huge chunk of
our money
but also bailing out the banks is
perpetuating a system which is never
going to work anyway so whatever we do
we're always going to have this cycle
until we separate how money is created
and the activities of banking then the
banks can do as they wish they're a
normal business like everyone else
there's a major democratic issue here as
well i mean you have these
private profit-seeking banks creating up
to 200 billion pounds a year and pumping
that into the economy
wherever they want basically wherever it
suits them
whether they're pumping it into you know
these toxic
derivatives or putting money into
housing bubbles just making housing more
expensive
200 billion pounds in 2007 of new money
coming into the economy created out of
nothing
and where that gets spent determines the
shape of our economy effectively so if
we're going to allow anybody to create
new money out of nothing then we should
at least have some democratic control
over how that money is used i mean it
would we rather have had that money used
for healthcare
to deal with some of the environmental
issues to reduce poverty or do you
rather have it to make houses more
expensive so that none of us can afford
to live in a house
you can see it as a subsidy a special
super subsidy to the banks
for the right to create money
which should be for the benefit of the
public
and spent through a democratic process
there's also another form of money which
is effectively an electronic version of
cash
and it's a type of money that the
commercial banks use themselves to make
payments between each other the higher
street banks don't want to be carrying
around huge quantities of money because
it's dangerous and it's inconvenient and
it's you know expensive you have to hire
security guards for that type of money
so what they do is they pay each other
in what is an electronic version of cash
which
in the industry is known as central bank
reserves
they keep this electronic cash in
accounts at the bank of england
but as a member of the public you can't
access this electronic cash you can't
get an account with the bank of england
what they do is they they effectively
sell this central bank money to the
banks
and they do this by creating it out of
nothing and using this money to pay for
bonds to buy bonds from
the high street banks
so the high street bank will come along
with a bond which is you know
effectively government debt and it will
give it to the bank of england and in
return the bank of england will type
some new numbers into the bank's account
at the bank of england so effectively
they're creating central bank reserves
out of nothing the bank of england
creates central bank reserves
by increasing the available credit in
the settlement bank's account with the
bank of england
the settlement bank in return post bonds
or sells assets as collateral for the
reserves
a total of 46 banks hold central reserve
accounts at the bank of england
smaller or foreign banks hold accounts
with one of these 46 banks to allow them
to accept or make payments in pounds
sterling
prior to march 2009 the bank of england
would ask each of the major settlement
banks how much reserve currency they
needed
the settlement banks would then swap a
bond for the reserve currency
and agree to repurchase the bond for a
specific amount
at a specified future date
the settlement banks would then receive
interest at base or policy rate for the
central bank reserves they held
since the crisis settlement banks
central reserves have shot up
dramatically
when bank customers transfer funds from
their account to another person's
account
a process called intraday clearing
occurs
the amount of central reserve currency
bank a has at the bank of england
is reduced by the corresponding amount
that bank b
this is the importance of central
reserve currency to banks
before the credit crisis
if a bank was short of central reserves
at the bank of england to meet its
obligations
then the bank would have to loan
reserves from other banks
with interest
if you sell something on ebay you know
that that deal's not complete until you
get some money put into your account you
know most people actually want to see
the money in their account before
they're happy to close on a deal now the
banks are pretty much the same but they
want to see the money in their account
at the bank of england before they
consider a deal complete
so for example if you
if you're buying a house from somebody
who banks with a different bank then
what will happen after you spend quarter
of a million on a house is you'll tell
your bank to transfer some money to the
house sellers bank
and what the bank will do is actually
instruct the bank of england to move
250 000 from their account at the bank
of england to the bank
of the house salary
and that money will actually move across
between the accounts at the bank of
england
when that money's moved across and the
banks will consider that that payment
has been made you know it's been settled
they
don't really deal in the kind of money
that we have in our accounts they deal
in this special money that's can only be
used at the central bank
there are millions of people across the
country all transferring money to each
other using only a few major banks
these banks can keep a tally on their
computer systems
and usually many of the movements cancel
each other out at the end of the day
the five major banks
rbs
lloyd's
hsbc
barclays and santander
hold over 85 per cent of all deposits
as there are a limited number of banks
in the system
the central reserve money can only be
moved around them in a closed loop
the money is just circulating through
this system over and over again
and if you think about it a one pound
coin could be used to make a billion
pounds of payments if it was circulated
a billion times and that's effectively
the system that you have now is you have
a small pool of real money that's just
going round and round the system and
it's being used to make a huge quantity
of payments on our behalf just before
the crisis there was only 20 billion
pounds in the accounts at the central
bank
if they don't have enough of this
central bank money then effectively they
can't make payments and if that happens
then pretty quickly the entire system
seizes up
so the bank of england has the
responsibility of making sure there's
enough of this money in the system
the requirements for banks to hold a
specific amount of reserves has changed
many times since 1947
at that time banks needed to hold a
minimum ratio of 32 percent of reserves
cash or treasury bonds to deposits
in 2006 the corridor system was
introduced
in which banks could set their own
reserve targets each month
[Music]
the rules changed again in march 2009
when the bank of england introduced
quantitative easing
quantitative easing in effect gives
settlement banks the central reserve
currency for free
[Music]
the central reserve currency is what is
referred to as the real money in the
fractional reserve model
but the fact is banks can have as much
of this as they want
and central reserve currency itself is a
form of fiat money which is backed by
nothing
as a consequence there is no longer a
meaningful fractional reserve
[Music]
if you look over the history of the last
150 years or so you start off
um with the development of a gold
standard that really comes to four in
the 1880s 1890s where essentially
countries peg themselves to a particular
defined value of gold and then they have
an agreement to
fix that value to hold that value and to
trade gold amongst themselves to make
sure the balances are all there and also
to try and restrict or expand or
contract um activity in their own
economies uh to make sure that the
balance that particular fixed prices is
maintained that disintegrates uh in the
well after the first world war i mean
this is where the whole thing breaks
apart very major dislocation in the
international monetary system at that
point not really resolved until you get
bretton woods agreements at the end of
the second world war in which everything
is paid to the dollar and the dollar is
paid to the gold so you kind of want to
remove from gold backing or saying that
there is a definite you know sort of
solid commodity money behind the paper
money in the credit money that we're all
using over here you're kind of one
removed from it
after hiroshima tokyo wondered when the
next atom bomb would fall
they did not wander along
[Music]
in 1944
at bretton woods
the us and the uk began to negotiate how
to govern the world economy the world
monetary system and came up with the
world bank and the imf and a series of
other institutions designed to manage
the global currency and there was still
a gold standard but this gold standard
was going to be tied to the dollar all
of the world's gold had moved from
london
to fort knox
and all of the world's currencies were
tied to the dollar
this system was designed to manage the
sorts of imbalances to avoid credit
crunches or for countries the credit
crunches are known as balance of trades
deficits i.e when they can't pay their
bills and their currency collapses the
currencies were managed
and the system was stable as long as the
americans played the role of oversight
now who knows the great story about how
that all came to an end
so the quantity of money that was needed
to pay for the vietnam war
that's
exactly what i was trying to get at oil
shocks was another one that meant that
the americans were no longer respecting
their role or playing their role
governing the monetary system they were
inflating the value of their own
currency but ostensibly was meant to be
tied tied to gold into every other
currency
so what did the french do
the french were a little bit worried
that president nixon wasn't entirely
honest
and they were worried that they were
that precisely what we described
that nixon was printing money when he
shouldn't have been what's going on and
they were worried there wasn't enough
gold to honor the exchange rate of the
french franc so they
sent a gun boat to new york harbor to
ever so politely ask for our gold back
please
did they get their gold
back
go on guess
they didn't and the bretton woods system
came to an end
and this is the point in which we enter
the modern era of the financial system
historically
money creation was pegged to a commodity
often gold
but today it is pegged to nothing
which means there is nothing backing our
money
this piece of paper
is just a piece of paper
where does this leave us
if money is based on nothing
why do we think it has any value
sorry
because we can still go and exchange it
where somebody else was going to shout
great little latin fact the word for
credit comes from
belief
correct
since the collapse of the dollar gold
standard in 1971 and the deregulation of
the financial system
money creation has grown exponentially
the world economic forum meeting in
davos
at the present time have called on a
need for
the credit within the
economy the global economy to be
expanded by
100
trillion
dollars 100 trillion us dollars a
trillion is 12 naught so 100 trillion
if you want to imagine is a one followed
by 14 knots
they believe this credit expansion will
create a boom
because there is now more money in the
economy with which to make investments
it's fascinating that this the emergence
of digital currencies how it's
transformed everything really because it
just completely unleashed private banks
to dominate and create the money system
that works for them and works for the
people who run private banks
if you want a growing economy under the
current set up we have to have growing
debt
you can't
you know this is something that very
very few people really understand
especially not the politicians who are
managing the economy which is a scary
thought
[Music]
as the money supply grows
more money is available
which can be invested in productive
avenues
however it can also be used to gamble
and drive up asset prices
[Music]
inflation is a rise in the general level
of prices of goods and services in an
economy over a period of time
when the general price level rises
each unit of currency buys fewer goods
and services
as the money supply grows and there is
more currency available
more money is available for investment
which can lead to growth
but more money is also available for
purchases of goods and speculation
which leads to inflation
essentially inflation is what happens
when too much money
is chasing too few goods and services
so that there's too much money for the
the actual output of the economy
in the seven years between 2000 and 2007
the money supply doubled and
the banks you know the central bank the
bank of england in this time
was under the impression that they had
it under control because they were
saying you know prices aren't going up
that much
of course they were only looking at
prices in you know in your local corner
shop they weren't looking at the price
of housing and housing is you know the
biggest
expenditure that most people will make
increasing house prices
it may
make you feel like you're you're
becoming wealthier but as your wealth
increases
the
effect is that your children's wealth is
actually decreasing so in fact there's
no net
gain in wealth because your children
are going to have to pay even more when
they want to buy a house so in effect
there's no there's no kind of net
increase they're gonna have to earn even
more they're gonna have to go into even
more
debt
so the
rising house prices do not create
additional
uh net gdp value to the economy it they
actually what they do is they
redistribute wealth
uh towards those people who already have
houses are wealthier people and remove
it from poor people who can't afford to
get on the housing ladder so it's
another example of a very regressive
policy actually to allow house prices to
simply
inflate
it makes everybody feel kind of like
things are going well
and people spend more money on other
stuff they take equity out of their
houses but it it's not creating new jobs
it's not
enhancing the quality of the economy
it's not helping our balance of trade
it's not helping a public deficit it's a
zero-sum game
as of august 2011
85.5 percent of consumer bank lending
was secured as mortgages on dwellings
if you have somebody creating money that
can only be spent on one thing which is
housing then the price of that thing is
going to go up between 2000 and 2010
they created over a trillion pounds of
new money
500 billion pounds just in the three
years before the crisis that's why house
prices went up the way they were there's
nothing you know special about houses it
was just all this funny money being
pumped into that market if money is
spent into the economy
a lot of money goes into houses for
example into mortgages
um
that's an increase in the amount of
money in the economy without a
corresponding increase in activity in
output
in gdp it's non-gdp based
spending
uh that's what causes
inflation in
in the uk we've we've had it in spades
we've had you know this massive uh
housing boom
and that the main cause for the housing
boom in my opinion is the huge amount of
speculative credit created by the banks
to go into houses if houses were cheaper
um
they would be
easier to build more there'd be more of
them would be built there would be less
huge houses with hardly any people in
them london would not be the center of a
kind of
very rich
speculative orgy where all the richest
people in the world wants want to get a
property in london because it's seen as
a great asset you know houses would be
seen as places to live primarily rather
than places to
invest
important thing to think about is if
you're a bank
and you've got to make a loan
you have choices you can you can give
that loan to
a small business
and you'll know that the risk to you of
that loan failing defaulting is actually
quite high because that small business
the owners of that business have limited
liability which means if the business
goes bust
you as a bank getting nothing back
essentially you know that's it so that's
kind of high risk compared to loaning
your money to somebody with some
collateral with a house behind them like
a mortgage so there's a there's a kind
of simple incentive for banks to prefer
putting money into housing than into a
small business
now that's a real problem
or if you if you if you widen that out
across a whole economy
because it means there's an incentive
you know to put money into speculative
rather than productive
investment so again we have to think
about how we create a monetary system
that is more balanced between those two
kinds of speculative and productive
investment the government's showing very
little uh
enormous reluctance to regulate the
housing market and to again regulate the
amount of money that that banks put into
houses we don't decide who creates
credit for what no we leave that to a
couple of chaps in the bank to decide
basically
a bubble occurs when there is very high
inflation in the price of a specific
good or service over a short period of
time
the idea of the tulips and their
relevance is that we saw the first ever
financial bubble and crash
the craze for tulips black tulips being
a mythical ideal of what somebody could
genetically engineer through cultivation
after many generations became a mania in
the netherlands in the 1630s
what they didn't realize was that many
of the very very rare patterns on tulips
were caused by a virus and weren't
genetic at all
but they traded them to the extent that
tulip bulbs got to the point where they
were worth 10 times the average annual
salary
of
a person working in the netherlands
there was a futures market in two lip
bulbs because obviously you plant them
now but you don't know what's going to
come out the ground so we see already
400 years ago that a money system or a
financial system is not something that
exists in the abstract somewhere out
there in the ether but something that
was to do with states
power
trade
and how they interact with each other
unlike tulips which are a disposable
luxury
houses are both a necessity and a luxury
and as such they are ideal as a vehicle
for money and bubble creation
a dwelling
is perhaps the most prized possession of
value most people aspire to
inflating house prices in this way
allows the nation to expand its money
supply
without affecting inflation data
the additional purchasing power created
increases the perceived wealth in
relation to other nations
and thus it creates relative power
it is a way of increasing monetary power
without investing in the productive
growth of industry
but certainly if you look at britain and
america as outstanding examples of this
these are countries with very high rates
of private home ownership so you've got
a good base to try and perform this sort
of policy off the back of i think it was
quite deliberate in the case of the u.s
almost explicit was alan greenspan as
head of the federal reserve
when confronted by a stock market crash
at the end of
the 1990s
quite deliberately slashed interest
rates to almost zero everyone can borrow
very very cheaply in particular it's
very easy to borrow against a house
because this is an asset and it's
potentially something that the bank can
say well okay we're not just lending
your money unsecured you actually do
have a house and that's great because we
can repossess it they won't tell you
this when you take the mortgage but they
can do this and that bubble is in what
fuels expansion such as it is inside the
u.s
and inside the uk where something
similar takes place for the next decade
or so i think it's also a reflection of
an underlying weakness of these
governments that they they simply
lack the will
and possibly the ability but i think it
more comes down to a will to challenge
financial markets to challenge big
capital and say we're going to do
something different now and you're going
to have to go along with it because
we've been democratically elected and
you lot frankly haven't and we have a
mandate to do this and we're going to
make this happen just remember it's all
part of the plan
what are you yapping about you voted for
it
in holland or in the netherlands what we
had over a period of trying to get
independence initially from spain and
trying to raise money to get an army to
free themselves
was financial innovation they innovated
public lotteries to get money together
they had public subscription this was
the idea that led to the idea of public
shares a piece of the action that
anybody could invest in that meant that
something like two-thirds of the
population was investing in tulip bulbs
by the 1630s
after independence these these
instruments were applied to financing
expansion
why was such a small country able to
hold its own against so much bigger
countries for example spain and portugal
that had the benefits of their empires
for over a century
in respect of the netherlands why could
they compete on what resource basis well
they had a more efficient a more
involved and a broader based financial
system with these instruments that
they'd innovated that allowed them to
bring more money to bear at one point
than anybody else more quickly
[Music]
but true
now inflation can be avoided
if the amount of money that goes into
the economy
is regulated in a way that it doesn't
exceed the actual activity that's
happening in the economy now
the best way to do that in my opinion is
to make sure that money is issued into
the economy only
for
productive
investment for productive
goods and services so money goes in
to
help a small business start up which
creates jobs which creates
additional purchasing power
which means there's no inflation
during their history almost all central
banks have employed forms of direct
credit regulation
the central bank would determine desired
nominal gdp growth
then calculate the necessary amount of
credit creation to achieve this
and then allocate this credit creation
both across the various banks and type
of banks and across industrial sectors
unproductive credit was suppressed
thus it was difficult or impossible to
obtain bank credit for large-scale
purely speculative transactions
such as today's large-scale bank funding
to hedge funds
the world bank recognized in a 1993
study that this mechanism of
intervention in credit allocation
was at the core of the east asian
economic miracle there's all sorts of
things that governments have done in the
past
very successfully in a number of cases
and not often not unsuccessfully in this
country but the examples that spring to
mind like south korea and japan often
any stage where government's been quite
targeted about how they're going to
rebalance the economy and picking
sectors and deciding where the
investment should take place i think
that has to start happening in the uk
because we're in a demand side recession
rather than looking at crisis of supply
you have to have a system
where credit is put into
productive
avenues where credit is put into
building high-speed rail links where
credit is put into
building houses rather than giving
people money to inflate the price of of
houses so it's it's quite simple really
in that way
and
the current system is simply set up not
to do that basically
the creation of money by private banks
for non-productive usage causes real
inflation
and as such it is attacks on the
purchasing power of the medium of
exchange
the figures for the uk are quite stark
actually that's
average median real incomes for so
that's you know what the bit in the
middle uh for most people declined over
the last eight years also they're now in
quite sharp decline as we go into the
recession i mean the sharpest really
since
it looks like since about the 1930s
probably that way so real incomes are
declining
bank-created fiat currency allows the
private banks to suck wealth from the
economy
and over time results in a gradual
decrease in the standard of living
as people become poorer they become even
more dependent on debt
and this at a time when efficiency and
machination have improved dramatically
you know you go back to the 1960s and we
were expected to to we were looking
forward to
an age of leisure what were people what
they were talking television programs
saying what's people going to do with
all their spare time
you know
and now we've got more people working
harder than ever
spending more than ever
which looks great you know when spending
more everyone says oh yeah
you know
but if you're not actually benefiting
from what you're spending if you're
having to spend the money on child care
costs on commuting costs you know and so
forth uh just you know costs that people
didn't in the past used to have to pay
because you know you could walk to work
and you know one member of the family
remain was able to to stay at home and
be a permanent homemaker then you're
actually much you're not actually any
better off you know everyone's under and
everyone's under such enormous pressures
nowadays
you know
i am conscious that
to say my four nephews and nieces
are facing difficult times
she's gonna find themselves having to
work
you know um
very hard just to keep just to keep a
roof over them just to get a roof over
there just keep a rope over their head
people are getting poorer in real terms
is because price is always going up
because all this new funny money is
being pumped into the system by the
banks
and they're creating it all as debt so
at the same time as prices are going up
and things are getting more expensive
we're getting further and further into
debt and you know our wealth
and the return that we get from actually
working is getting less and less all the
time when you can't
deal with poverty when you have a
financial system and a money system that
distributes money from the poor to the
very rich
any distribution that you try and do in
the opposite direction is
um you know it's effectively pressing in
the wind if you look at issues like you
know increasing inequality
one obvious way to tackle inequality is
to have say for example a redistributed
tax system you know you tax the rich you
give some money to the poor you move
money down down the scale
that's all very well but if you
completely overlook the fact that
there's another redistributive system
which is taking money from the poor and
giving it to the rich
then you're not really going to tackle
this inequality
and
the way
a debt-based money system works it
guarantees that for every pound of money
there's going to be a pound of debt now
that debt is typically going to end up
with you know the poor
uh the sort of lower middle classes
those people end up with the debt and
they end up paying interest on that
money which then goes back to the
banking sector and gets distributed to
the people working in the city or in
wall street
um and what this what this system does
overall is it distributes money from
from the poor to the rich essentially
distributes money from you know the
poorer regions of the uk
back to the city of london
and it also distributes money from all
the small businesses you know all the
little factories
around the uk and distributes that money
back into the financial sector we have a
system
whereby
the activity of actually supplying
occurs under the very same roof as the
same organization that's responsible for
profiting from putting together
borrowers and lenders i.e a bank
so a bank
creates our nation's money supply as
well as
making loans
for profit the government cannot allow
the banking system to fail
because if it did
over 97 of all money would disappear
this is why in the event of a crisis the
risk is transferred to the taxpayer
but even during normal times banks
receive numerous guarantees and benefits
beyond the right to create money bill by
the way i know the bank of america is a
very big bank it happens i've got thirty
two dollars there myself
just between us what assurance do i have
that this money is safe
well uh all deposits up to ten thousand
dollars are assured are insured by the
federal government in washington that's
my guarantee yes
have you heard that the federal
government is about 280 billion dollars
in the hole
[Applause]
banks receive large safety nets from the
government
the taxpayer guarantees 85 000 pounds as
deposit insurance
and the bank of england provides
liquidity insurance in case a bank runs
out of reserve currency
someone wrote that a big investment bank
is like a giant vampire squid
around the face of humanity
hypnotizing politicians who throw money
at the banks
no strings attached
no matter what damage is done
trashing the planet forcing cuts to
things that make life better
goodbye schools
goodbye playgrounds
goodbye jobs
the bankers that we bailed out
then gave themselves bonuses that were
bigger than the first wave of public
spending cuts
britain alone gave the banks
more money than it cost to put a man on
the moon
six times over
where did our money go
who let the banks get away with it
why
can vampire squids ever be useful
no government yet is brave enough to
tame them
perhaps
they need a plan
the spending cuts agenda is an attempt
by the government to shift debt from its
account
to that of the public
this is the government's response to the
bank bailouts and is necessary in a
debt-based monetary system
where increased purchasing power is the
result of growing debt
and where a diversification of debt
provides overall stability and market
confidence
policies such as student fee increases
and the privatisation of public services
assets and industry follow the same
model
the problem we're facing i think is that
uh
there's been there's this transference
from the public debt to the private debt
which is a which is essentially a way of
transferring risk actually away from
sort of uk plc and the government on to
the heads of individuals and it's going
to be the most vulnerable individuals
who are going to have the most debt
thus it's a very unprogressive
regressive
policy framework that the government's
embarking on where the risk is moved on
to those who are most vulnerable and if
there is another financial shock if
there's an oil shock for example the
people who will pay the penalty are
those are the poorest people in society
or homeowners for example who will fall
into negative equity if interest rates
go up even one or two percent uh they'll
be real really big problems so
i don't think it's a sensible way
forward at the moment at all and it's uh
regressive and it's certainly not fair
in the terms that
the government's talking about and it's
certainly not a case of we're in this
together
as more of a country's resources and
industries are privatised the private
sector takes on more debt
as a result more money is created and
there is a boom
some private equity companies have taken
this theory to the extreme
engaging in a practice known as a
leveraged buyout
where a company is purchased at an often
inflated price and the purchase price is
transferred to the business as a debt
the company becomes responsible for the
funding of its own purchase
these debts are often so great that the
company needs to reduce staff salaries
and research activities
when you have to factor interest as a
business if you have to factor interest
repayment into your goods and services
then you have to charge a perpetually
higher price as you take on more and
more debt
an increase in the diversification of
debt results in an increase in the money
supply when the money supply increases
more money is available for productive
activities and consumption
which is the condition for a boom
it's questionable whether we're going to
get out of this recession or whether
we'll just keep taking along the way
that we are now
however if we do
then
when we come out of this recession when
growth starts again
look at what happens to debt it will
rise and it will keep rising and the
faster the economy is growing the faster
the debt will rise and then give it
another
three to five years
we'd be back where we were you know the
debt will become too much people will
start defaulting again
it's kind of the system that we're
locked into now is we can't we can't
grow the economy without growing the
debt and the debt is the very thing that
will bring down the economy
the only option going forwards is to
reform it to stop banks from creating
money is that
by fixing the monetary system we can
prevent the banks from ever causing
another financial crisis and we can also
make the the current you know public
service cuts and the tax rises and the
increase in national debt are necessary
the current monetary system allows the
banking sector to extract wealth from
the economy whilst providing nothing
productive in return
i mean why is it that we've got all this
technology um
you know all this new efficiency
and yeah it now requires two people to
finance a household
whereas in the 50s it only needed one
person working and the reason for that
is not because you know these washing
machines and everything are more
expensive it's because of all the debt
and it's because you know effectively
the banking sector is creaming it off
from everybody else so a growing banking
sector isn't a sign you know it's not a
good thing if the banking sector is
growing it's either that it's becoming
less efficient or it's becoming a
parasite on the rest of the economy and
that's you know we can talk about the
banking sector becoming four percent
five percent six percent of gdp
what's happening to the rest of the
economy is becoming 96 95 94 percent of
gdp we've got to get switched on to this
now you know if we want to if we want to
have a chance of tackling any of the
other big social issues you've got to
figure out the money issue
the poorest in the world pay for crises
even when they've not benefited from the
um the the often
reckless and speculative booms like the
housing boom in in ireland that preceded
that crisis you know over the last 30
years we've seen
income differentials increase
so that the rich have got much much
richer
and ordinary people haven't they've
stayed the same or they've they've got
poorer
and one of the ways that the economy was
kept going was by providing cheap credit
was provided providing debt to those
very people who couldn't really afford
things anymore and so they kept buying
and when it collapses it's those same
people that
have to pay once again even though in in
many ways they were the victims the
first time around
as a result of the crisis the bank of
england has bought corporate debt
and repackaged it at lower rates of
interest
yet the average person is being asked to
pay more than ever to borrow an
overdrafts and credit cards
debts between the very wealthy um or
between governments can always be
renegotiated and always have been
throughout world history they're not
anything set in stone it's generally
speaking when you have debts owed by the
poor to the rich that suddenly debts
become a sacred obligation more
important than anything else um the idea
of renegotiating them becomes
unthinkable
can you pin down exactly what would keep
investors happy make them feel more
confident
that's a tough one
personally uh it doesn't matter that
that's it i'm a trader uh i don't really
care about that credit
[Music]
where you voted
if i see an opportunity to make money i
go with that so
for most traders we don't really care
that much how they're going to fix the
how they're going to fix the economy how
they're going to fix the uh the whole
situation
our job is to make money from it and
personally i've been dreaming of this
one for three years
if you know what to do you can make a
lot of money from this i i had a
confession which is
i go to bed every night i dream of
another recession i dream of another
moment like this
i dream of another recession a dream of
another moment like this
you can make a lot of money from
[Applause]
[Music]
the way in which you can look across
europe now and see that the new prime
minister east not elected essentially
imposed papademos former employee of
goldman sachs the new prime minister and
finance minister of italy mario monty
former employee of goldman sachs the new
president of the european central bank
former employee of goldman sachs it's
quite you know you kind of see these
people popping up absolutely everywhere
that's the way to change what we have
take all power and all freedoms away
from the people and collect everything
into the hands of one small group with
absolute power
from the people
without the people
against the people
what's been interesting out of all this
i suppose is the question of democracy
that's been opened up very starkly in
europe that you have a government bank
has essentially imposed on you it's
bankers who more or less got into this
mess to put it rather crudely but that's
a good first approximation to it and
then you say okay bankers are the people
who therefore going to get us out of it
and instantly they're going to run your
your country now there's a serious
question democracy that's opened up here
by the way the banking crisis
drove more than a hundred
million people back into poverty
the mortality statistics of people who
go into poverty
rise hugely
for a whole range of reasons
so the banking crisis isn't just about
becoming poorer it was about killing
people as well
and guess what
we haven't really got to the bottom of
it we never held anybody to account and
we haven't done the radical reforming
job that we really needed to do
because we
mistakenly thought
if we destabilize the position any
further it'll make matters worse and
guess you took the decisions all the
people who were there in the first place
i think you ought to know that the
business of one of these businessmen is
murder
their weapons are modern
they are thinking
2 000 years
out of date
look i was there when the secretary and
the
chairman of the federal reserve came
those days and talked with members of
congress about what was going on it was
about september 15. here's the facts and
we don't even talk about these things on
thursday at about 11 o'clock in the
morning
the federal reserve noticed a tremendous
drawdown of uh uh
money market accounts in the united
states to the tune of 500 550 billion
dollars with being drawn out in a matter
of an hour or two
the treasury opened up its uh a window
to help they pumped 105 billion dollars
in the system and quickly realized that
they could not stem the tide we were
having an electronic run on the banks
they decided to close the operation
close down the money accounts and
announce a guarantee of two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars per account so
there wouldn't be further panic out
there that's what actually happened if
they had not done that
that their estimation was that by two
o'clock that afternoon
five and a half trillion dollars would
have been drawn out of the money market
system of the united states would have
collapsed the entire economy of the
united states and within 24 hours the
world economy would have collapsed
[Music]
when money is withdrawn internationally
from one currency to another
the reserve currency shifts from the
national bank of one country
to the reserve account of the foreign
bank
foreign banks have relationships with
local banks that allow them to hold
foreign reserve currencies whilst not
being a part of the central bank scheme
at the local central bank
for example
when one thousand pounds is transferred
into euros
a uk bank will agree an exchange rate
with the euro area bank
perhaps 1.15 euros to the pound
the uk bank will then transfer a
thousand pounds of the central reserve
currency to the uk partner bank of the
european bank
whilst the european bank will transfer
1150 euros of reserve currency to the
european partner bank of the uk bank
what happens when currencies and the
exchange rate system is no longer
managed what are some of the first
consequences
devaluations
speculation
imbalances where some countries would
accrue more and more and more
what what would they accrue
other currencies
other currencies
the reserve currency needs to be spent
in the country of origin
or exchanged into other currencies
most foreign banks do not have
deposit-taking accounts outside of their
national borders and as such
the foreign reserves they hold do not
come back to them in the form of
deposits
when a country accumulates trade
imbalances
it either accumulates foreign reserve
currencies
in the case of surplus
or spends its own reserves
in the case of negative trade balances
balance of trade is is basically
the difference between what you're
selling abroad and what you're buying
from abroad now the feature on the the
uk
is that for a very long period of time
it's had a deficit on something called
visible balance of trade which is
trading things about things that you can
see so that is goods that you'd
recognize stuff you can put in
containers it's cars computers things
that you'd see in a shop that's been in
substantial deficit for i think it
opened up in the
did open up in the early 1980s and
essentially it hasn't it hasn't gone
away since if anything has got wider and
wider
foreign exchange reserves cannot be
directly used for domestic spending
the money can only be spent abroad
or on imports
a country with a large balance of trade
deficit
relies on its creditors to spend the
imbalances accrued in its own market
there have been proposals in the past to
try and create a mechanism
for those imbalances to match up
so keynes for instance john maynard
keynes
at the end of the second world war his
original proposal for
what became bretton woods and the set of
institutions set up there like the imf
and the world bank was that there will
be a kind of international clearing
union uh this is particularly relating
to the trade side rather than the sort
of the financial side directly but the
principle was that you know once trade
balances had opened up everybody would
bank through an international clearing
bank
and that would kind of force everyone to
to eventually reconcile
the imbalances that appeared in the real
economy
but no such mechanism exists
the accumulated net trade imbalance for
the uk is around 800 billion pounds
in essence what has happened is that
over many years some countries have had
big trade surpluses
and others big trade deficits
the countries with trade deficits have
been spending more than they've been
earning so they've had to borrow from
abroad and they've been doing this year
after year
countries like that to the united states
ourselves
and some other countries in europe that
cannot go on
and there are two ways in which this can
come to an end either and we're seeing
this in some other countries in europe
if they can't find new ways to become
competitive then their ability to repay
the debts is called into question
another way of doing it which we
followed is that we got a credible plan
to repay our debts
and the value of sterling has fallen by
25
to make our exports more competitive and
attractive to overseas buyers and it to
be more attractive for british consumers
to buy from british producers rather
than overseas producers
that is what we have done to put in
place framework to rebalance our economy
and i'm sure that's the right way to do
it
currency war
also known as competitive devaluation
is a condition where countries compete
against each other to achieve a
relatively low exchange rate for their
currency
as the price to buy a particular
currency falls
so too does the real price of exports
from that country
domestic industry receives a boost in
demand both at home and abroad
it's made british exports appear rather
cheaper so they've kind of recovered a
little bit but because the rest of the
world is now looking really quite ropey
they've started to fall back down again
so what we're looking at is something
that
almost a kind of anarchy and in a way
the increasing anarchy this is what's
happened over the last few years where
the brazilian finance minister has been
most vocal about this uh talking about
currency wars talking about the desire
of national governments when confronted
by a major recession they think if we
could export more we could dig ourselves
out of this recession if we want to
export more we depreciate our currency
that makes olga's cheaper everyone else
buys them we'll all be better off now
the issue here is if you depreciate it's
like everybody else appreciates against
you their stuff becomes more expensive
so they're not too happy about that they
also want to depreciate and this is
where you can see a competitive rounded
evaluations breaking out to decrease the
value of its national currency
a national central bank sells reserve
currency into the market
it creates this currency out of nothing
by typing numbers into a computer
[Music]
during the long phase of commodity money
the exchange rate would depend on the
amount of gold silver
or copper contained in the coins of each
country
similarly after the advent of paper
money and the gold standard the exchange
rate depended on the amount of gold the
government promised to pay the holder of
the banknotes
these amounts did not vary greatly in
the short term
and as such exchange rates between
currencies were relatively stable
after the second world war currencies
were pegged to the dollar
and the dollar was backed by gold
this system came to an end in 1971
so we have a modern financial system
where money
is now chaotically organized there is no
exchange rate because there's no gold
standard system to sustain
so we don't need it in fact we believe
the market will resolve all the problems
of exchange whether your currency should
be worth more than mine is a reflection
of your economy relative to mine and if
that changes the currency and the
exchange rate can change and if we need
that to happen it will happen magically
by the efficiency of market and profit
seeking and you guys know the rest i
think
a currency's value in relation to
another currency is determined by the
market
if more people want to buy a currency
than sell it
its value
increases if more people want to sell
its value decreases
the value is set by individual banks
as they buy and sell currencies they
will adjust the exchange rate
in the last study i read in 2007
each day on currency markets
3.2 trillion dollars are traded each day
who knows what the global gdp is
50. again brucy higher
60 that's closer
the point is think about that exchange
happening every single day there's about
260 business days a year
it takes a few weeks to match the global
value of every economic transaction that
happens everywhere every day in a year
and it takes a few weeks
obviously all of us trade currency and
fairly fairly regular if you go abroad
you exchange into another currency
that's a form of currency trading you're
swapping your pounds into whatever euros
or
yen or whatever it might be that happens
fairly regularly and that's a
conventional part of the trading process
you know large corporations have to do
this
on a regular basis where it becomes
something that people question um where
you get people saying well hang on this
is speculation is when you get people
realizing that currencies move around
next to each other and if they move
around in value next to each other
there's always an opportunity to try and
make money out of those changes in value
and therefore you can speculate on it
and that's that's the more sort of
questionable end of the market that's
the bit of the market that things like a
financial transactions tax would try and
chop away at because the assumption
there and it's it's kind of not
incorrect is that this just produces
instability for everyone else that these
people want volatility in the market
because that's how they make their money
they want to encourage it and they do
encourage it by trading and speculating
in the way that they do
by 2010
the foreign exchange market had grown to
be the largest and most liquid market in
the world
with an average of four trillion dollars
of currency being exchanged every day
volatility creates a need what does it
do to countries especially perhaps small
ones like developing countries if there
are suddenly huge and
instantly fluctuating financial flows
what do they have to do to cope
increase their production and sell more
lowering the price
and becoming possibly even poorer once
you start talking about the
international system it becomes really
quite a peculiar uh quite peculiar thing
in that a lot of it depends on simply
sentiment and beliefs about what an
economy is like rather more than depends
on anything the economy might or might
not actually be doing and that can shift
very very rapidly because you know if
it's just somebody's belief about
currency is supportable
then you know they can carry on
believing this until well to whatever if
that belief changes it can change very
rapidly in a financial market the
process of financial contagion can can
take place you know in just
minutes seconds even that you can just
move from being apparently quite a
stable robust
economy to being one that suddenly
sentiment has turned against you and you
find that markets are picking on you and
it can often be not much more than
you're simply the next-door neighbor of
uh you know a country that's currently
in trouble
many of the world's financial crises in
the past 30 years have been caused by
rapid withdrawals of the nation's
currency
or the currencies of an entire region
this type of activity is often referred
to as financial warfare
it's benefited
major institutions really quite
substantially the goldman sachs for
example or any large bank has done
somewhat better out of this set of
arrangements than it would have done in
a far more regulated environment it's
made people very very wealthy it's
allowed financial markets to expand
absolutely enormously
anybody involved in that is keen on
seeing a deregulated world in the case
of the uk you have a government which
has been quite
overtly and deliberately and
aggressively arguing against any forms
of regulation being imposed on those
financial markets but it's not the case
that someone's behind the scenes pulling
the strings it's it's this is this is
how the thing works quite deliberately
quite you know overtly in front of you
that's the world as it is it's making
some people very rich they're quite
happy with it
i think it is a form of
economic warfare um
much of the the change in the in the way
that the global economy works over the
last 30 years result from this this debt
this third world debt because it's given
rich countries and banks and the
financial sector enormous amounts of
power and control over the poorer bits
of the world where a lot of the
resources are that we like using and
that's being used in a way that many
people have compared to a form of
colonialism it's a very real direct form
of of power that's being used over those
countries to force those countries to do
what are really in the interests of the
richest segments of the world that they
do and as a result of that not only have
corporations become absolutely in very
you know made huge amounts of profits
and become absolutely enormous and and
um and all pervasive um but the
financial sector has become even bigger
than that and the and the real money in
in the world uh to be made today is not
by producing anything at all it's simply
by forms of speculating basically making
money from money that's the most
profitable and and by far and away
the the biggest form of of activity of
economic activity that exists in the
world today
to protect themselves vulnerable
countries need to accrue currency from
rich countries
who create these currencies out of
nothing
the netherlands first governor general
of indonesia the man who built the trade
routes fortified them
what i mean by that is built forts along
them and fought spanish fleets and
british fleets said about the
development of the spa of the of the
netherlands empire netherlands trade
was
we cannot make trade without war nor war
without trade
money and power
so reserves have become the way in which
you can insure yourself against what
speculation you said speculation
speculative attack
fallen markets
bubbles
when a country succumbs to a speculative
attack
it is asked to deregulate its markets
and conform its financial system
to that of the dominant party
the big problem that's faced by most
developing countries who got into a debt
crisis was that they were told by the
powers that be in the world the
international monetary fund which is in
many ways governs the the global
financial system that the way to get out
of debt actually is first of all to to
restructure your economy especially to
increase your exports so you're earning
more more dollars and then you can pay
off your your debt which is normally in
dollars or some other
foreign currency um unfortunately time
and time again that was proved to to not
be the case at all actually countries
cut back their public spending to the
bone so they stopped
growing they stopped having any
potential
for growth
and what they did produce was was um was
aimed at the export market was aimed at
creating dollars and so on so they were
paying off their debts but they weren't
developing their own economy at all they
were paying far far far more in debt
repayments than they were spending on
health or education or anything else and
their debts just kept getting bigger and
bigger and bigger
the country becomes a vassal state
allowing large corporations to exploit
its natural resources and workforce
it's not it's not even shadowy there's
no great mystery about about what's
happening here and about the way the
world operates it's like it's it's quite
blunt i mean for the last 30 years
you've got something pretty much
everywhere it certainly spreads pretty
much everywhere that generally gets
labeled neoliberalism this idea
that you should have floating exchange
rates you know weak regulation
particularly financial markets minimal
government
interference or involvement with what
market does and that's that's more or
less how the world operates and then
there are institutions and the
outstanding one at this point is the imf
that will actively try and enforce this
state of affairs so it's it's not
greatly shadowy if you see what i mean
that there are people behind the scenes
somewhere trying to manipulate stuff
it's actually this is quite this is
quite a verse this is happening and this
is how uh for
entire my entire adult life actually is
what it starts to look like this is how
the world the world is operated and it's
made some people very very wealthy it's
produced enormous concentrations of
wealth so when the international
monetary fund comes in in order to try
and
alleviate a country's debt problems it
imposes a set of conditions and in the
1980s and 90s they called that set of
conditions structural adjustment
structural adjustment program and it
tends to take very similar forms
wherever it happens and indeed we can
see structural adjustment programs in
essence happening today in countries
like greece and portugal and ireland
where countries are instructed to
decrease the amount that they spend on
the public sector
they are instructed to liberalise their
trade market and liberalise their
capital market so money can much more
easily come in and out of their economy
and the idea is this will encourage
investment to come in from richer parts
of the world
and that all of their problems will be
solved from this investment and in
actual fact this has proved time and
time again to be
completely without foundation in actual
fact what happens is it destroys
fledgling industries and capacities in
these developing countries and
developing countries become completely
dependent on goods and services from
developed countries and also from
capital from developed countries
one of the things the international
monetary fund is very is very
keen on is telling countries to lower
the taxes that should be paid by
multinational corporations when they
come and operate in a country because
then you'll encourage more multinational
corporations to come in of course what
it also means is the profits that are
made by those multinational corporations
leave the country just as quickly and
the country itself doesn't benefit and
today you have many developing countries
which have got almost no tax base
they've not developed a tax base at all
and so they're even more dependent on
international capital markets on the
money markets on creating debt
and that's why you have so many
countries in the world that have really
been robbed of their sovereignty it's
very difficult to see how democratic
societies can evolve or function when
actually a government is more dependent
on the dictats of the international
monetary fund and the money markets than
it is on their own people
what we've seen since the 1970s is a
dramatic increase
in a series of phenomena that have had a
seri a stimulative effect on the changes
in the financial system that have
brought us to the gleaming shining metal
and steel
business that's over there
in case you don't know that's the city
of london i'm pointing at
to compensate for the lack of a defined
commodity-based value underlying
currencies
financial institutions developed
securitization
as a means to manage risk
you develop securitisation as a means to
try and stabilize the whole system this
is a set of financial processes and
financial innovations that really
accelerate from the 70s 80s onwards you
had a chaotic system that needed to
manage risk and you had to innovate you
needed derivatives options futures you
have new markets in volatility
management tools who knows what the term
hedging is
spreading your risk managing your risk
insuring against your risk precisely up
until very recently you know there's up
until the 1960s the securities and
exchange commission would be quite clear
that you know derivatives that weren't
based on real products like agricultural
products so pork belly futures or
whatever would in fact be essentially
kind of gambling and therefore you
weren't allowed to trade that changes in
the 60s and everybody can trade you know
currency futures
things that are not based on real
products being traded at some point in
the future but based on movements of
currency prices
once you have the system of fixed
exchange rates breaks down obviously
this thing accelerates enormously so as
you get the roll back of government
regulation here you get the market taken
over with its own products here and the
theory is that the market is better at
regulating itself it's more stable than
if you have a government interfering all
the time the efficient markets
hypothesis the idea that you know you
set up a financial market they're fast
everybody in them is well informed they
all keep a very careful eye on what
everyone else is doing it will therefore
uh be very stable and it reflects real
changes in the economy it's not going to
be driven by
you know panics and manias and
speculative bubbles nonetheless really
going to happen if there is movement up
and down it's because something real is
happening and traders and investors in
the financial market responding to it
that's the efficient market's hypothesis
the practice i think what you see in
2008 is the kind of end of that process
the appearance of this crisis so major
the belief that it will simply be
self-stabilizing and self-regulating
really can't carry on i mean the
practice carries on anyway but you can't
really argue in the same way they used
to that it's good or it's necessary or
this is okay for the world
in the last decade we had a new
innovation something called the credit
default swap a way of buying insurance
against the company you've invested in
going bust
and in 2002 they were less worth in
total less than a trillion dollars in
2007 they were worth 60 trillion dollars
that's five years
everybody's somebody sitting there and
thinking oh these cdo's we've made uh
don't in fact provide the kind of
stability that we thought the maths
that's inside of them is complete
nonsense it turns out
there's a far more risk attached to
trying to securitize risk and securitize
debt in the way that we have done this
than we thought
and we think these things are worthless
the attempt to get more and more complex
ways of
regulating and shaping a financial
market and trying to make a quick buck
out of it as well
actually help produce the
the opposite effect to what its kind of
apologist said which is it led to led to
a spectacular crash
what we saw as a result of this very
different situation was one phenomenon
above all one sector above all grew and
that was the financial sector
while the financial sector benefits
enormously from the current monetary
system
the system is neither stable nor fair
the assumption
in what the bank of england does right
now
is that the cash that we hold is backed
up by government debt the government can
back up as promises by the fact that it
can tax the public
so what they're implying is that cash is
backed up by government debt when
government debt is backed up by the
ability of government to get cash from
the public time and time again over the
last 30 years we've seen
private debts being transformed into
into public debts and
the ultimately the price of that debt is
paid by
by the public in the in the debtor
country
this is why spending cuts are necessary
the system is designed to make certain
people very rich at the expense of a
nation's citizens and taxpayers
the system lowers the standard of living
of the majority
and distributes this wealth among the
privileged
so what we're left with is a financial
system since the early 70s that has no
fixed exchange rates that suddenly has
increasingly open financial borders
that has
central banks having to manage without
having any control because there's
nothing here where the gold used to be
chaotically they have to ease
quantitatively
they have to
lend as a lender of last resort
throughout history
monetary systems were designed to give
the dominant international power
an
advantage and this power is fiercely
defended and expanded on
what i would like to see
is
a
new kind of currency that is backed by
something that that is scarce and that
we really need and we really value
something like energy or renewable
energy for example so a sort of
kilowatt-hour backed
currency would be would be very
interesting to me we need to start
valuing the things that are most scarce
um
and that we need to survive as a human
race in the long run and backing an
international currency with something
like that
will generate enormous investment in for
example renewable energy
if that's the you know the primary
international
unit of account that's that's that's
being used uh another option is is a
basket of of currencies so you you know
you mix up the value of of of different
currencies um to create a very solid
currency that people have confidence in
perhaps even better would be a basket of
commodities with which to back up
international currencies
now if it was possible
internationally some way or another to
get all these competing and increasingly
competing national economies together
and say
we're all going to sit down and write
out an agreement somewhat like the
bretton woods agreement which will allow
for unlike bretton woods allow for you
know some currencies to be paid against
different buses and goods that are more
appropriate to their national economies
and you can sort of arrange this if you
could arrange that to happen
then that would be nice and you can see
how that would start to create a kind of
order in the international macro economy
which is otherwise lacking the real
difficulty there is just political is
that who on earth is going to do this
who is the force that's going to
kind of make this thing happen
creating a monetary system which is both
fair and stable is possible and can be
achieved
what are international organizations for
if not for such a purpose
[Music]
this
is george
george worked in a big bank in the city
of london
but
one day without warning george's bank
went bust
luckily the government rescued the bank
and george kept his job but
the greedy government wanted something
in return for their help
they demanded a higher tax on george's
salary and bonus
for someone with a high cost lifestyle
like george a shock like this can be
devastating
[Music]
now george struggles to afford the rent
on his riverside apartment in central
london the tyres on his aston martin are
wearing thin and are barely road legal
unless george's situation improves or
unless someone like you helps him and
george may even be forced to walk past
the next several row tailors and buy his
suit from topshop or next
even if george had anything to celebrate
he can no longer afford the champagne to
celebrate with
george is not alone
countless others are suffering like him
and no one knows how long it will be
until the good times return
[Music]
but
with your help
george can turn his life around
a simple monthly donation from you can
bring a bit of sunshine back to george's
life
just 395 pounds will help him celebrate
minor achievements with a magnum of
cristal champagne
as little as 900 pounds will help george
buy a new set of tyres for his aston
martin
two thousand pounds can help george
recover his self-esteem with a suit from
a prestigious savile row table
but even a small amount will help
just 200 pounds will buy a meal for
george and his girlfriend experience
just 200 pounds extra will buy the
drinks
by adopting a banker
you won't just be supporting someone
like george in a time of need
you'll also be supporting the trendy
wine bars of the city of london the
luxury car makers of italy and the
tailors of savile row
you'll be doing your patriotic duty to
support britain's greatest industry in
its time of need
and when the good times return and
george gets his bonus back the taxes he
pays will help fund the public services
that the rest of you scroungers depend
on
so please
until the good times return for george
and those like him
will you give today
[Music]
you